This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。欢迎在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《学得艰难》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方其实都不安全的诚实对话，但你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难的方式。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transition. of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。你好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活转变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理学意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. Thanks for tuning in. It's so great to have you back for another episode of the psychology of your 20s. Today, by popular demand, we're going to be discussing the psychology of a quarter life crisis. I'm sure we've all heard.
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众。感谢收听。很高兴大家能回来收听又一期的《20多岁的心理学》。今天，应广大听众的要求，我们将探讨四分之一人生危机的心理学。我相信大家都听说过。
of a midlife crisis that typically happens in our late 40s, early 50s, you know, the archetype of men buying convertibles and leaving their wives or their partners, women dying their hair pink or purple, getting a poodle, I don't know, marrying younger people, quitting their jobs, all of those well-known tropes and stereotypes. I feel like this is a pretty highly recognized and satirized concept, but what about the quarter life crisis that usually happens in our 20s? It doesn't seem like many people are talking about that as much. Maybe you're hearing it for the first time today, but I assure you, it is very much a real thing. It's an important thing to discuss. So the term quarter life crisis, it's relatively new across the field of
中年危机，通常发生在40多岁晚期、50多岁早期，你知道，那种男人买敞篷车、离开妻子或伴侣的原型，女人把头发染成粉红色或紫色，养一只贵宾犬，我不知道，和年轻人结婚，辞职，所有这些众所周知的俗套和刻板印象。我觉得这是一个被高度认可和讽刺的概念，但是通常发生在20多岁的四分之一人生危机呢？似乎没有多少人在谈论这个。也许你今天是第一次听到，但我向你保证，这绝对是一个真实存在的事情。这是一个值得讨论的重要话题。所以“四分之一人生危机”这个术语，在
psychology and self-help and wellness, but essentially what it explains is a period of panic, of uncertainty, a meltdown of sorts, where we start asking ourselves these really big existential questions we may not have thought about before. The outcome of that is somewhat of a crisis moment where we feel completely shocked and lost and looking to make some big changes. More of than than not, it's centered on those three big things. Career, love, context, or location. I know that sounds like four, but career love context or location is three. We begin to feel worried about what we're doing in our lives, whether our relationships fulfill us, whether our lives fulfill us, and if we're in the right place. So how can psychology explain this
心理学、自助和健康领域相对较新，但它本质上解释的是一段恐慌、不确定、某种崩溃的时期，在这期间我们开始问自己一些从未想过的大型存在主义问题。其结果是某种危机时刻，我们感到完全震惊和迷茫，并希望做出一些重大改变。大多数情况下，它集中在那三件大事上。职业、爱情、语境或地点。我知道这听起来像四个，但职业、爱情、语境或地点其实是三个。我们开始担心我们在生活中做的事情，我们的关系是否让我们满足，我们的生活是否让我们满足，以及我们是否在正确的地方。那么心理学如何解释这个
occurrence, this period of intense instability and uncertainty and questioning, this period of intense fear. How can it explain the subsequent kind of inexplicable urge to change up our lives, to quit our jobs, move to a new city, break up with our long-term partner, shave our heads, completely transform ourselves? This is something I am so interested in, especially as I can feel my own quarter-life crisis kind of looming. In fact, I feel like I'm already very much in it in some ways. And I'm sure many of you are in the same boat as I am and as many of us are, especially as our late 20s and 30s approach. And we're surveying our surroundings and freaking out a little bit. So I think it's really important to kind of tackle some of those
现象，这段充满强烈不稳定、不确定和质疑的时期，这段充满强烈恐惧的时期。它如何解释随之而来的那种莫名的冲动：改变我们的生活，辞职，搬到一个新的城市，和长期伴侣分手，剃光头，彻底改造我们自己？这是我非常感兴趣的事情，尤其是当我也能感觉到我自己的四分之一人生危机即将来临的时候。事实上，我觉得自己在某些方面已经深陷其中了。我确信你们中的很多人也和我以及我们许多人处于同样的处境，尤其是随着我们20多岁晚期和30岁的临近。我们在审视周围环境时有点抓狂。所以我认为以某种方式解决其中一些
unanswerable questions in a way. You know, where is my place in the world? What is my purpose? what the actual heck am I doing with my life? Well, whilst I might not be able to answer those questions for you today, what we will be doing is starting from the beginning. What is a quarter life crisis? What does the experience indicate about our growth and our journey? Why do we tend to panic as we enter the tail end of our 20s? And finally, perhaps the most important element of this episode is
无法回答的问题真的很重要。你知道，我在世界上的位置在哪里？我的目的是什么？我到底在用我的生活做什么？好吧，虽然我今天可能无法为你解答这些问题，但我们要做的将是从头开始。什么是四分之一人生危机？这种经历说明了我们的成长和旅程的什么？为什么我们在进入20多岁尾声时往往会感到恐慌？最后，也许这一集中最重要的元素是
How do we use this experience as a springboard for our growth and self-actualization and greater happiness? So so much amazing content to cover, so much learning to come, I hope. So buckle in for this week's deep dive into the quarter life crisis. Okay, so we need to start from square one and get our basics down pat. What is a quarter life crisis? When we talk about a quarter life crisis, we're thinking primarily about that period in our lives when we hit our 20s. For most of us, it's at this stage that we really start looking at our lives and probably
我们如何利用这段经历作为我们成长、自我实现和获得更大幸福的跳板？所以有这么多精彩的内容要涵盖，有这么多的学习要进行，我希望如此。系好安全带，开始本周对四分之一人生危机的深入探讨吧。好的，所以我们需要从头开始，把基础知识搞懂。什么是四分之一人生危机？当我们谈论四分之一人生危机时，我们主要是在思考我们20多岁时生活中的那段时期。对我们大多数人来说，正是在这个阶段，我们真正开始审视自己的生活，并且可能
thinking we have a good 80 or so years on this planet. We are a quarter of the way through that, hence the word quarter. and the reality of the finality of life can really just hit us square on, that here we are at 23, 24, 25 years of age, whatever age we're at. And we are a quarter of a way through our lives. And what? What do we have to show for that? What are we even doing?
认为我们在这个星球上还有大约80年的光景。我们已经经历了其中的四分之一，因此有了“四分之一”这个词。而生命最终性的现实真的会当头棒喝，我们在23、24、25岁的年纪，无论我们处在什么年龄。我们已经度过了生命的四分之一。然后呢？我们有什么成果可以展示？我们到底在做什么？
Firstly, something to get straight, this experience is absolutely normal. And I think I would be more concerned if someone didn't have this experience because it's a pivotal moment of redirection, of clarity and growth that is essential for our development. A quarter life crisis, it's not a clinical term. You're not going to find it in the DSM or get a diagnosis. it's actually a very subjective, highly individual, kind of existential crisis of sorts that is often seen in people in a certain phase of life who've started asking themselves some pretty big questions that they've never asked themselves before
首先，需要明确的一点是，这种经历绝对是正常的。而且我想，如果有人没有这种经历，我反而会更担心，因为这是一个重定向、清晰度和成长的重要时刻，对我们的发展至关重要。四分之一人生危机，这不是一个临床术语。你不会在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中找到它，也不会得到一个诊断。它其实是一个非常主观、高度个人化、某种存在主义的危机，通常出现在处于人生特定阶段的人身上，他们开始问自己一些从未问过的大型问题
and this results in some really deep and scary soul searching around some of those critical components of our life, our careers, our relationships, our financial, situation, our ambitions. Massive, massive things to tackle all at one time. And if you're finding yourself in this period of stress, of doubt, of anxiety, kind of wanting to borrow down or run away, you're certainly not alone. I found this LinkedIn study. I think it was done last year or maybe the year before, but it found that 72% of the young people they surveyed had experienced some form of a quarter-life crisis with 33% of them currently kind of in the throes of said
这导致了围绕我们生活中那些关键组成部分——我们的职业、我们的关系、我们的财务状况、我们的雄心壮志——进行一些非常深沉且可怕的灵魂拷问。同时要应对极其巨大的事情。如果你发现自己正处于这种压力、怀疑、焦虑的时期，有点想钻牛角尖或逃跑，你绝对不是孤单的。我发现了这项领英（LinkedIn）的研究。我想这是去年或前年做的，但它发现他们调查的年轻人中有72%经历过某种形式的四分之一人生危机，其中33%的人目前正处于上述
quarter-life crisis. It's such a common experience, 72%. And the average age of this crisis is about 26 to 27, and it lasts about 11 months. But it can happen at any age. at any time around this period. This estimation or figure of, you know, 26 to 27, though it makes sense, doesn't it? It's at this age that our 30s are looming the next major chapter of adulthood. We feel like we have enough life experience to be an adult, but don't exactly feel that way. Sometimes we find ourselves starting completely from scratch, completely from scratch, you know, ending long-term relationships with people we thought we would marry, suddenly finding ourselves really dissatisfied with our professional lives, wishing we'd made a different choice, and just feeling
四分之一人生危机的水深火热之中。这是一种如此常见的经历，72%。这场危机的平均年龄大约是26到27岁，持续约11个月。但它可以在任何年龄发生。在这个时期的任何时间。这个26到27岁的估计或数字，虽然讲得通，不是吗？正是在这个年龄，我们的30岁若隐若现，这是成年期的下一个主要篇章。我们觉得我们有足够的生活经验来成为一个成年人，但又不完全有这种感觉。有时我们发现自己完全从零开始，完全从零开始，你知道，结束了那些我们以为会与之结婚的人的长期关系，突然发现自己对职业生活极度不满，希望自己当初做了不同的选择，而且感觉
all around super lost. And whilst that internal struggle is happening, what's going on around us? You know, we're seeing people that we know slowly get married, have children, live their passion, get promoted, and, you know, seem like they have everything together, whilst we, at least from personal experience, are still making mistakes, and that can really exacerbate already those internal feelings of dissatisfaction. I had this experience the other day, actually, whereby most of my friends have these lovely partners, the people they've essentially decided to spend their life.
整个人超级迷茫。而在这场内心挣扎发生的同时，我们周围又发生了什么？你知道，我们看到我们认识的人慢慢结婚、生孩子、过着他们热爱的生活、升职，并且，你知道，看起来他们一切都安排妥协了，而我们，至少从个人经验来看，还在犯错，这真的会加剧本已存在的内心不满情绪。其实我前几天就有过这种经历，当时我的大多数朋友都有这些可爱的伴侣，也就是他们基本决定共度一生的
lives with and I'm still here with my bad date stories, you know, another failed talking stage or terrible but funny hookup story, making the same mistakes, doing the same thing that I've done since I was 18 or 19 whilst everyone around me seems to have grown up, you know, seems to have gotten everything together. I think another thing to consider is that our 20s are this weird vacuum between our teenage years and what we see as proper adulthood, you know, our 30s and our 40s. And there are all of these opposing kind of decisions and opposites to consider. We have these societal expectations that we should be getting settled. We should settle down.
人，而我还在这里带着我那些糟糕的约会故事，你知道的，又一段失败的暧昧期或者糟糕但有趣的露水情缘，犯着同样的错误，做着我从18、19岁以来一直在做的事情，而我周围的每个人似乎都长大了，你知道的，似乎都把一切都搞定了。我认为另一个需要考虑的事情是，我们的20多岁是我们十几岁和我们视为真正成年（也就是我们的30多岁和40多岁）之间一个奇怪的真空地带。这里面有所有这些相互冲突的决定和对立面需要权衡。我们有社会的期望，认为我们应该安定下来。我们应该成家立业。
But our brains are still developing and we're still exploring what we would like to be. We feel like we need to have a grasp over things like our finance. and our careers. But at the same time, we're seeing all of these other things around us change. We're having all of these deep conversations and questions of ourselves. And externally, in the real world, you know, there's massive inflation, there's unemployment, climate change, unaffordable housing, lower incomes compared to the expectations that were set by the generation before us by our parents, those expectations of having it together, of having a house, of knowing what you want to do with your life, they're no longer realistic.
但我们的大脑仍在发育，我们仍在探索我们想成为什么样的人。我们觉得我们需要掌握诸如财务和职业之类的事情。但与此同时，我们看到周围所有这些其他事情都在发生变化。我们对自己进行了所有这些深层的对话和质问。而在外部的现实世界中，你知道，有巨大的通货膨胀、失业、气候变化、负担不起的住房、比上一代人（我们的父母）为我们设定的期望更低的收入，那些一切都搞定、拥有一套房子、知道自己想用生活做什么的期望，它们不再现实了。
I've been having this conversation and this discussion with my friends more and more where our childhood visions of our lives are just no longer realistic. Like, it's just not happening. We're not going to be millionaires anytime soon at least. We start to abandon some of our big aspirations. Normally that's creative endeavours, like our musical or artistic ambitions. We forget about, you know, the white picket fence or a home on the beach or being a world traveler. Because that now costs like millions of dollars.
我越来越多地和朋友们进行这种交谈和讨论，我们童年对生活的愿景根本不再现实了。就像，这根本不会发生。至少在短期内我们不会成为百万富翁。我们开始放弃一些宏伟的抱负。通常那是创造性的努力，比如我们的音乐或艺术野心。我们忘掉了，你知道的，白色的栅栏、海滩边的家或成为世界旅行者。因为那现在要花好几百万美元。
It costs a lot of money and that realization that what we wanted as children isn't exactly as achievable. as it seemed is such a bitter, hard pill to swallow. And it can be a massive trigger for what will become a quarter-life crisis. You know, sometimes where we are right now isn't where we want to be. It's not where we imagined we would be at this age. You thought things would turn out differently, and they're not. You know, when I was 15, 16, I had to be. I. thought I was going to be really successful by now, like really successful, you know, maybe even married or at least with someone I love. I thought I'd be a homeowner. I definitely thought I'd be making more money, maybe traveling, and I thought that I would know what I wanted to do with my life.
这需要花很多钱，而意识到我们小时候想要的东西并不像看上去那么容易实现，真是一颗苦涩难咽的药丸。这可能是引发四分之一人生危机的巨大导火索。你知道，有时我们现在所在的地方并不是我们想去的地方。这不是我们想象自己在这个年龄应该在的地方。你以为事情会朝着不同的方向发展，但并没有。你知道，当我15、16岁的时候，我必须是。我。以为我现在会非常成功，非常成功，你知道的，甚至可能已经结婚了，或者至少和某我爱的人在一起。我以为我会成为房主。我绝对以为我会赚更多的钱，也许会去旅行，而且我以为我会知道自己想用生活做什么。
And in some ways, that's true, right? Like, I get to make this podcast. That's what I want to do in my life, right? Like, I really enjoy doing this, but everything is still quite confusing. And there are all these different thoughts and feelings floating around in my head. You know, I wanted this incredible life for myself of jet-setting and maybe writing a novel or going to Europe with my soulmate. That's a bit, like, ridiculous to me now that I'm in my, like, mid-20s. But that's just how life turns out. You know, don't get me wrong here.
从某些方面来说，这确实是真的，对吧？比如，我能做这个播客。这就是我想在生活中做的事情，对吧？就像，我真的很喜欢做这件事，但一切还是相当混乱。我的脑子里飘浮着所有这些不同的想法和感受。你知道，我为自己想要那种惊艳的生活，坐喷气式飞机到处飞，也许写一本小说，或者和我的灵魂伴侣去欧洲。现在回想起来，当我处在20多岁中期的时候，这听起来有点荒谬。但生活就是这样发展的。你知道，请不要误解我的意思。
Like, please, don't misconstru. my words, like, I absolutely love my life, and I wouldn't have it, like, any other way. Like, I love my life. I've had these incredible experiences and growth these past years, and those periods were, you know, so much more than I could have imagined as a child. But as the years go by, and I kind of find myself lapsing into stagnation and feeling comfortable in what I have, I realize I haven't. achieved some of those dreams and I panic. I panic a little bit more. I worry if I'm doing
就像，拜持，请不要曲解我的话，就像，我绝对热爱我的生活，我不会让它变成别的样子。就像，我热爱我的生活。过去几年里，我有了这些不可思议的经历和成长，那些时期，你知道的，远远超出了我童年的想象。但随着时间的流逝，我发现自己陷入了停滞状态，对拥有的东西感到安于现状，我意识到我还没有实现其中一些梦想，我感到恐慌。我更加恐慌了。我担心自己是否在
this right. It's such a quintessential experience of our 20s to be questioning our path forward and our path to this point, right? Like, and then that's, you know, there's that existential knowledge that lingers that we're so aware of in our 20s as we gain more self-awareness. and more appreciation of the world, that this is, you know, our only shot. You don't get another shot at life. And here we are, a quarter of the way through, and, you know, I really better make that count. And I'd better be sure of my decisions. It's so much pressure.
做正确的事情。质疑我们前方的道路以及走到这一步的道路，是我们20多岁时的一种典型经历，对吧？就像，然后那是，你知道的，那种挥之不去的存在主义认知，我们在20多岁获得更多的自我意识和对世界的更多赞赏时，对此是如此清醒，即这（你知道的）是我们唯一的生命机会。你不会有第二次人生机会。而我们现在在这里，已经度过了四分之一，而且，你知道，我真的最好让它有价值。我最好对我的决定感到确定。这压力太大了。
It can be quite stifling to come across that realization. And that's a really common train or pattern of thought for those of us who are going through a quarter-life crisis right now. it's a pattern of thought that many psychologists or therapists tend to hear. They tend to get these visits from people in their 20s who all of a sudden wake up one day with that realization, that the decisions they make count and they start questioning the ones that they've made. You know, am I in the right place for me?
遇到这种认识可能会相当令人窒息。对于我们这些现在正在经历四分之一人生危机的人来说，这是一种非常常见的思维轨迹或模式。这是一种许多心理学家或治疗师经常听到的思维模式。他们往往会接待这些20多岁的人，这些人突然有一天醒来时有了这种认识，意识到他们所做的决定很重要，并开始质疑他们已经做出的决定。你知道，我是在适合我的地方吗？
Am I doing what I want? You know, life is moving so fast and I feel like I have to really. change something about my life. Otherwise, I'm not going to be happy. In this way, a quarter-life crisis is very much like an existential crisis, which is, I guess, a whole other episode. It's really similar to this. You know, a quarter-life crisis is the existential crisis of our 20s. In psychology, this kind of crisis, it occurs when we begin to question things like meaning and purpose. And the purpose of our life, of our existence, the realities of death, you know, just some fun casual topics. And obviously, the answer to these questions is not easy to come by. If we don't really have
我在做我想做的事吗？你知道，生活过得太快了，我觉得我必须真正改变我生活中的某些事情。否则，我不会快乐。从这个意义上说，四分之一人生危机非常像存在主义危机，我想这也是另一整集的内。容。这与此非常相似。你知道，四分之一人生危机是我们20多岁时的存在主义危机。在心理学中，这种危机发生在我们开始质疑诸如意义和目的等事情时。我们生活、存在的目的，死亡的现实，你知道，只是一些有趣随意的热门话题。显然，这些问题的答案并非易事。如果我们真的没有
the answer to them, and they require a lot of deep contemplative thinking about our values, what brings us joy, the impact we want to have on the world, many of which are questions that are shared between a quarter-life crisis and an existential crisis. And it's almost a rite of passage, right, that we all go through this in our 20s in order to exit out onto the other side of real adulthood. I don't know. Maybe not real adulthood, but some more mature kind of adulthood, where we feel like we have our lives together. at the center of a quarter life crisis is really a struggle for meaning.
它们的答案，并且它们需要对我们的价值观、什么给我们带来快乐、我们想对世界产生什么影响进行大量深入的沉思，其中许多问题是四分之一人生危机和存在主义危机所共有的。这几乎是一种成年礼，对吧，我们所有人都在20多岁时经历这一切，以便走向真正成年期的另一端。我不知道。也许不是真正的成年，而是一种更成熟的成年，让我们觉得我们把生活搞定了。在四分之一人生危机的核心，其实是一场对意义的挣扎。
Meaning in life, the meaning of life, is impossible to define. It's really difficult because it's a highly personal decision. It's a highly personal experience. But researchers, they've kind of defined it as the feeling that our lives are significant, that they're purposeful, that they're career. In other words, that we have a direction that makes sense to us and gives us a feeling of worth. And when we're in our 20s, we're so young to have figured that out, because we've really only just come into our mature selves and the struggle for a purpose, for a meaningful job, the need
生命中的意义，生命的意义，是无法定义的。这真的很难，因为这是一个高度个人的决定。这是一次高度个人的体验。但研究人员将其定义为一种感觉：我们的生活是有意义的、有目的的、有方向的。换句话说，我们有一个对我们有意义并给我们带来价值感的发展方向。而当我们20多岁的时候，要弄清楚这一点实在太年轻了，因为我们真的才刚刚进入成熟的自我，对目的、对有意义工作的奋斗，这种对
to make that contribution, it can be paralyzing. And when we can't make sense of that, We can't make sense of the understanding that this is a normal experience, the typical symptoms and experiences and reactions of dread and stress and anxiety and a meltdown, feeling unfulfilled, they follow along pretty quickly after that. The need for purpose, I think, is one of the defining characteristics of human beings. We crave purpose. We really do. and we suffer some pretty serious psychological difficulties when we don't have it.
做出这种贡献的需求，可能会让人感到瘫痪。当我们无法理解这一点时。我们无法理解这是一种正常经历，随之而来的典型症状、经历以及恐惧、压力、焦虑和崩溃、感到不满足的反应，很快就会接踵而至。我认为，对目的的需求是人类的决定性特征之一。我们渴望目的。我们真的渴望。当我们没有它时，我们会遭受一些相当严重的心理困难。
Purpose is like a fundamental component of a living and of living a fulfilling life. And it's so important that it's even measured on most tests of well-being and most ways of assessing our mental health. They'll ask you, like, do you feel like you have purpose? There are a number of psychological explanations for what? why it's so important. But the one that I find, perhaps the most fascinating, was featured in psychology today, which is this online site. And I found, I stumbled across it when I was researching this episode. And it made so much sense to me. It made so much sense. When we feel like we have direction or something to work towards, this makes us less vulnerable to something
目的就像是生活和过上充实生活的一个基本组成部分。它是如此重要，以至于它甚至在大多数幸福感测试和评估我们心理健康的大多数方法中进行测量。他们会问你，比如，你觉得你有目的吗？对于为什么它如此重要，有许多心理学解释。但我发现也许最吸引人的一种解释刊登在《今日心理学》（Psychology Today）这个在线网站上。我在研究这一集时偶然发现了它。这对我来说太有意义了。这太有意义了。当我们觉得我们有方向或有可以努力的目标时，这会使我们对某种被称为
called psychological discord. And that is this recognizable sense of unease. We get when our attention isn't occupied by external things. And when we don't have something that drives us, it results in boredom, but following on from that, also anxiety and depression and a crisis. By having a purpose and an intentional purpose, you know, something we actually really care about and something to focus on. We in some ways protect ourselves from these feelings, these feelings of anxiety and distress, and it gives us a channel for our energy and the energy that is contained in every one of us, and it gives us a channel for our ambition. It's also essential for personal development and societal development as well. So when we begin to question whether we're
“心理不和谐”的东西的脆弱性降低。那是我们在注意力没有被外部事物占据时产生的一种可识别的局促感。当我们没有驱动我们的东西时，它会导致无 boredom（无聊），但接踵而来的还有焦虑、抑郁和危机。通过拥有一个目的和有意识的目的，你知道的，一些我们真正关心的事情和可以专注于的事情。我们在某种程度上保护自己免受这些感觉的影响，免受焦虑和痛苦的感觉，它为我们的能量以及包含在我们每个人当中的能量提供了一个渠道，它为我们的野心提供了一个渠道。这对个人发展和社会的持续发展也至关重要。因此，当我们开始质疑我们是否在
contributing and whether our lives have meaning, that's why it can be so abrasive. because it goes against that core fundamental need, that psychological need, to have something to do that feels important to you. And that's essentially the core of a quarter life crisis, right? If you're at this point, this crossroads in your life right now, where you're looking at the things you've been doing, what you've been working towards, your career maybe, and are just thinking, like, this is not what I want. I'm not happy. This is not who I want to be. It's probably because that doesn't align to your purpose. And it's probably because, you know, when you decided what you wanted to do, you were 17, 16 years of age. And you're not that person anymore. You're not that person. And things
贡献以及我们的生活是否有意义时，这就是为什么它会如此具有摩擦力。因为它违背了那个核心的基本需求，即心理需求，去做一件对你来说很重要的事。这基本上就是四分之一人生危机的核心，对吧？如果你现在正处于人生的这个十字路口，看着你一直在做的事情、你一直在努力的方向、也许还有你的职业，然后觉得，这不是我想要的。我不快乐。这不是我想成为的人。这可能是因为它不符合你的目的。这可能是因为，你知道，当你决定你想做什么时，你才17、16岁。而你已经不是那个人了。你不再是那个人了。随着我们承担更多责任，并且在我们进入20多岁中期和晚期时觉得自己需要成为一个成年人，事情
get so confusing as we get more responsibilities and feel like we need to be an adult as we enter into our mid and late 20s. So I want to talk about how this crisis can manifest, but also ultimately why it's firstly really normal and secondly, incredibly, incredibly important. Our next partner has a product I use literally every day. I started taking AG1 because I've been on a bit of a health journey. I wanted to take better care of my immune system and my gut health. And with one delicious scoop of AG1, you're essentially absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins, minerals, probiotics, all that good stuff. And it's really great for your nervous system and your immune system.
变得如此令人困惑。所以我想谈谈这场危机是如何表现的，以及最终为什么它首先非常正常，其次，极其、极其重要。我们的下一个合作伙伴的产品我真的每天都在使用。我开始服用AG1，因为我一直在经历一段健康之旅。我想要更好地照顾我的免疫系统和肠道健康。只需一勺美味的AG1，你基本上就能吸收75种高质量的维生素、矿物质、益生菌和所有这些好东西。它对你的神经系统和免疫系统真的很好。
It's just one simple micro-habit that you can incorporate into your daily life with big benefits. It's super lifestyle-friendly. And Athletic Greens is also a climate-neutral certified company, which we absolutely love on the show. Right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system. with a convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop in a cup of water every day. That's it. No need for a million different pills and supplements to look after your health.
这只是一个你可以融入日常生活的小习惯，却有着巨大的好处。它非常符合生活方式。而且Athletic Greens也是一家气候中和认证公司，我们在节目中绝对非常喜欢这一点。现在，是时候通过便捷的日常营养来重获健康并武装你的免疫系统了。每天只需在一杯水中加一勺。就是这样。不需要为了照顾健康而吃一百万种不同的药丸和补充剂。
And to make it easy, Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one-year supply of immune supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash gemma. Again, that's athletic greens.com slash gemma to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance. Let's talk about how a quarter life crisis can manifest and why at the end of the day it's incredibly important for our growth, not something to be avoided. There are some common stresses, firstly, that I think are important to discuss because they can contribute to this kind of crisis.
为了方便起见，Athletic Greens将为您首次购买提供一年的免疫支持维生素D免费供应以及五个免费旅行装。你所需要做的就是访问 athletic greens.com 斜杠 gemma。再次重申，那是 athletic greens.com 斜杠 gemma，以掌控你的健康并挑选终极的日常营养保险。让我们来谈谈四分之一人生危机是如何表现的，以及为什么归根结底它对我们的成长极其重要，而不是应该逃避的事情。首先有一些常见的压力，我认为讨论它们很重要，因为它们会导致这种危机。
and as important as I like to say it is, it can be really uncomfortable. So noticing why it is that this may have occurred or why it is that you're feeling this way is really crucial. The first one is so common. You know, you're planning your career, job searching. You've got your first job out of uni or trying to choose your major. You're graduating. You know, maybe you've even been through a few jobs.
尽管正如我喜欢说的那样它很重要，但它可能会让人感到非常不舒服。因此，注意到为什么会发生这种情况或为什么你会有这种感觉是至关重要的。第一种非常普遍。你知道，你在规划职业生涯、寻找工作。你刚从大学毕业拿到第一份工作或者试图选择你的专业。你毕业了。你知道，也许你甚至经历了几份工作。
And you're trying to figure out what it is about, your life that you want to focus on. I think one of the scary realisations of our 20s, if we choose to take the full-time work route, is that we're going to spend most of our lives inside an office. That's really terrifying. And for some, that's a dream, right? But for others, it's really not what they want.
你试图弄清楚你生活中想要关注的是什么。我认为20多岁时最可怕的认识之一，如果我们选择走全职工作路线的话，就是我们将把大部分生命花在办公室里。这真的很可怕。对某些人来说，这是个梦想，对吧？但对其他人来说，这真的不是他们想要的。
This is a massive one, planning our careers. In this day and age, our identity is so, closely tied to our career and our professional lives. This begins even in our childhood and our adolescence with an emphasis on questions about, you know, what do you want to be? What do you want to do? Rather than asking young people, what makes you happy? Why do you want to do that with your life? So when we go through a quarter life crisis and we begin contemplating our meaning and our purpose, we don't actually know how to answer those questions because we've been taught to be goal-orientated rather than value-orientated.
这是一个巨大的问题，规划我们的职业生涯。在这个时代，我们的身份与我们的职业和职业生活如此紧密相连。这甚至始于我们的童年和青春期，当时重点强调的是诸如“你想成为什么样的人？”、“你想做什么？”之类的问题。而不是问年轻人：“什么能让你快乐？”、“你为什么想用你的生活做这件事？”。因此，当我们经历四分之一人生危机并开始思考我们的意义和目的时，我们其实并不知道如何回答这些问题，因为我们被教导要以目标为导向，而不是以价值观为导向。
Instead of thinking about what makes us happy and instead of contemplating the life we imagine, we're kind of forced into this limited thinking about what do I want to achieve, what do I want my job title to be? And that's not really a way to create a meaningful life because it's quite transparent, it's quite shallow. So when we get to the point where we do get to have some agency and really think about what it is that's going to make us happy, if we've never asked ourselves those questions before,
我们没有去思考什么能让我们快乐，也没有去构思我们想象中的生活，而是被迫陷入这种狭隘的思考中：我想实现什么，我的职位名称应该是什么？这其实并不是一种创造有意义生活的方式，因为它太透明了，太肤浅了。因此，当我们到达真正有自主权并认真思考到底是什么能让我们快乐的节点时，如果我们以前从未问过自己这些问题，
particularly when we think about how we're going to make money and our careers, it can be really overwhelming. We might also find ourselves living away from our family for the first time. maybe you're living alone or in a new city, away from your family unit. And that really challenges how we see ourselves. And that kind of move into independence is one of the first early hallmarks of being an adult. And it's really hard to find where we stand and to figure out our identity beyond what we were offered as a child. The other thing is navigating relationships.
特别是当我们考虑到如何赚钱和我们的职业时，这可能会让人感到非常不知所措。我们可能还会发现自己第一次远离家人居住。也许你独自居住或在一个新的城市，远离你的家庭单位。这确实挑战了我们看待自己的方式。而这种走向独立的转变是成为成年人的早期标志之一。要找到我们的立足点，弄清楚超越童年所给予我们的身份，真的是一件很难的事情。另一件事是导航人际关系。
You know, our relationships, particularly the romantic relationships that we have, but equally our friendships are one of the most important determinants in our life. They're so crucial. It cannot be overlooked. So making those choices about what's going to make us happy, but more importantly, who's going to make us happy is actually a really big question and a really big stressor. Maybe you're finding yourself in a relationship right now that you've been in for sometime. It could be a high school sweetheart.
你知道，我们的人际关系，特别是我们拥有的浪漫关系，还有我们的友谊，是我们生活中最重要的决定因素之一。它们太关键了。这是不容忽视的。因此，做出关于什么能更让我们快乐的选择，但更重要的是，谁能让我们快乐的选择，其实是一个非常大的问题，也是一个巨大的压力源。也许你发现自己正处于一段已经维持了一段时间的关系中。它可能是高中甜心。
Could be someone you started dating in uni. And you're thinking, is this what I want my life to be? Do I want to be with that person? On a grander scale, you know, do I want to be friends with these people? Is this the person I want to be? It can be such a challenging question, right? And sadly, I can't give you the answer to that. I wish I could. I wish I could ease your struggle.
可能是你在大学开始约会的人。而你在想，这真的是我想要的生活吗？我想和这个人在一起吗？在更宏大的尺度上，你知道，我想和这些人做朋友吗？这就是我想成为的人吗？这可能是一个极具挑战性的问题，对吧？遗憾的是，我无法给你答案。我希望我能。我希望我能减轻你的挣扎。
but part of the quarter-life crisis is that something that you have to figure out for yourself. You're also making, like I said, long-term personal and professional decisions. You know, they might not always have anything to do with your job or your romantic partner or where you live or, you know, your connection with your family. It doesn't always have to do with that. But kind of these broader decisions about the life you want, you know, including things like financial investment. and financial decisions and questions about your life values. Like, do I really want to work in an office?
但四分之一人生危机的一部分就是，那是你必须自己去弄清楚的事情。正如我所说，你也在做出长期的个人和职业决定。你知道，它们可能并不总是和你的工作、你的浪漫伴侣、你居住的地方或者你与家人的联系有任何关系。它并不总是和那有关。但这些关于你想要的生活的更广泛的决定，包括财务投资等事情
Is that really the life I want for myself or do I maybe want to travel? You know, there's pros and cons to both. And it's an equation and a decision that we have to make. But it can also be a real catalyst for going through this crisis period. So the Harvard Business Review, I know, very fancy. But they did this report and they found that a quarter life crisis, the one that, you know, typically occurs in our 20s, it normally presents in four phases. So first of all, if you're going through this and you feel like you're going through this,
和财务决策以及关于你的生活价值观的问题。比如，我真的想在办公室工作吗？这真的是我想要的生活吗，还是我可能想去旅行？你知道，两者各有利弊。这是一个我们需要做出的方程式和决定。但它也可能成为经历这段危机期的真正催化剂。因此，我知道哈佛商业评论（Harvard Business Review）非常高大上。但他们做过这样一份报告，发现四分之一人生危机，也就是通常发生在20多岁时的危机，通常呈现为四个阶段。首先，如果你正在经历这个，并且觉得你正在经历这个，
you really can relate to some of these experiences. I think this is an important thing to break down, right? Like what's the trajectory? What's the path through this crisis period? That can sometimes bring us a lot of comfort. So firstly, often if you're going through this, people are going to feel a sense of being trapped in some form of commitment, either in your personal or your professional life. This is synonymous with the feeling of almost claustrophobia and the sense that you cannot,
你真的可以与其中一些经历产生共鸣。我认为这是一个需要剖析的重要问题，对吧？轨迹是什么？度过这段危机期的路径是什么？这有时能给我们带来很多安慰。所以首先，通常如果你正在经历这个，人们会感到被某种形式的承诺所困住，无论是在你的个人生活中还是在你的职业生活中。这几乎等同于幽闭恐惧症的感觉，觉得你不能，
you know, kind of escape the constraints of life. Like you're stuck, you're trapped, you're stuck in your full-time job, you're stuck in your relationship. And this sense of being trapped is often accompanied by depression and panic, feeling lost and stuck the anxiety we were speaking of before. This is the beginning of the crisis. You're looking around and you're feeling like, I don't like where I am.
你知道，逃避生活的束缚。就像你卡住了，你被困住了，你被困在你的全职工作中，你被困在你的关系中。这种被困住的感觉常常伴随着抑郁和恐慌、迷茫和停滞不前的感觉，也就是我们之前所说的焦虑。这是危机的开始。你环顾四周，觉得：我不喜欢我现在所处的地方。
This is not where I wanted to be. I feel like I'm trapped in this situation. Following this, there's often some kind of action and a desire to break away and change things. I don't know if you've experienced this, but when I went through kind of a bit of a quarter-life crisis, this a year or so ago, right when I started this podcast, actually, the first thing I wanted to do was, like, chop off all of my hair, chop it all off, quit my job, get in my car, travel around with no
这不是我想去的地方。我觉得自己被困在这种境况里了。在此之后，往往会出现某种行动以及打破现状、改变事物的渴望。我不知道你有没有经历过，但当我在一年多前经历了一点四分之一人生危机时，实际上正是我开始做这个播客的时候，我首先想做的事情是，把我的头发全部剪掉，全部剪掉，辞职，上车，漫无目的地旅行，没有
direction, no plan, just freedom, and hopefully find my purpose in life and the way forward. It's kind of, now that I know, now that I know that this is actually really indicative of some kind of crisis or meltdown that's occurring, I can see that really clearly. I felt stuck and I wanted to escape. It's our breaking point where we eventually get tired of feeling so shit about our lives and confused and desired to make some kind of a change. And if we don't do this, we kind of risk living with this sense of unease and unhappiness for the rest of our lives.
计划，只有自由，并希望找到我的人生目标和前进的道路。现在我知道了，既然我知道这实际上确实表明发生了某种危机或崩溃，我可以非常清楚地看到这一点。我感到被困住了，我想逃避。这是我们的崩溃点，我们最终厌倦了对自己的生活感觉如此糟糕和困惑，并渴望做出某种改变。如果我们不这样做，我们就有可能在余生中带着这种不安和不快乐的感觉生活下去。
So it's an important step, that action, that break away. It's crucial. And this leap of faith, or this break away from, our current reality, it's not always a pretty feeling. It's not always a pretty picture. It's defined in many ways by a really deep separation and loneliness as we leave places and relationships of really deep comfort and really deep convenience. For example, you know, leaving a job that you've had for years or a long-term relationship or a place that you've lived since childhood, it's going to be really hard and it's going to be really uncomfortable and sometimes
所以这是一个重要的步骤，那种行动，那种打破现状。这至关重要。而这种信仰的飞跃，或者说对我们当前现实的打破，并不总是一种美好的感觉。它并不总是一幅美好的画面。在许多方面，它的特征是深深的分离和孤独，因为我们离开了那些给我们带来深深舒适感和便利感的地方和关系。例如，你知道，离开一份你做了多年的工作、一段长期关系或者一个你从小居住的地方，这会非常艰难，会非常不舒服，有时甚至会
painful because it's all new and unknown. And with that comes, you know, essentially isolation. But sometimes feeling alone and unsure of ourselves is actually a really important part of the growth. During this period of isolation, during this period of confusion, we get the opportunity to really reflect on our life and what our purpose actually is and begin to try, maybe it's, you know, a new activity or a new place, new friends, new social groups, new career opportunities and come out on the other side of the crisis, feeling more sure of who we are, having had the time to sit with ourselves and sit with a really uncomfortable feeling and question our values and hopefully come to an answer. Although it's an uncomfortable
痛苦，因为这一切都是崭新的、未知的。随之而来的本质上是孤立。但有时感到孤独和对自己的不确定，实际上是成长中非常重要的一部分。在这段孤立期、困惑期，我们有机会真正反思我们的生活以及我们的目的到底是什么，并开始尝试，也许是一项新活动或一个新的地方、新朋友、新社交圈、新的职业机会，然后从危机的另一端走出来，更加确信我们是谁，因为我们有时间与自己相处，与那种非常不舒服的感觉相处，并质疑我们的价值观，希望得出一个答案。尽管这是一个不舒服的
experience, it's also really important. And it can be a springboard for some really essential growth and to flourish in your next chapter of life and this amazing new chapter. And this is kind of linked to the last thing I really want to talk about today. I think a quarter life crisis gets a bad rap. Yes, it's sometimes awful. Yes, it is characterized by incredible mental discomfort. And if you're experiencing it right now, I really do feel for you. Like, I don't envy you at all. I know how it feels. And I can promise you'll get through it, but I can't promise it will be easy,
经历，但它也非常重要。它可以成为实现一些真正必不可少的生长的跳板，并在你人生的下一个篇章和这个精彩的新篇章中蓬勃发展。这与我今天真正想谈的最后一点有关。我认为四分之一人生危机名声不太好。是的，它有时很糟糕。是的，它的特点是令人难以置信的心理不适。如果你现在正在经历它，我真的对你感同身受。就像，我一点也不嫉妒你。我知道那是什么感觉。我向你保证你会挺过去的，但我不敢保证这会很容易
but it will be like essential, essential for your growth. Questioning your purpose in life and the overall meaning in life, it's obviously never going to be a walk in the park. But sometimes we go through hard things for good reasons. And this is one of those examples. It's the perfect time to do some of that deep thinking and contemplation that I think in my opinion is something that we all have to do at some stage. What would happen if we really never questioned our path in life?
但这将是至关重要的，对你的成长至关重要。质疑你的人生目标和生命的整体意义，显然永远不会是一帆风顺的。但有时我们经历艰难的事情是有好原因的。这就是其中一个例子。这是进行一些深度思考和沉思的绝佳时机，在我看来，这是我们所有人在某个阶段都必须做的事情。如果我们从来没有质疑过自己的人生道路，会发生什么？
What if we never questioned our dreams or our place in the world? If you never pushed yourself to be uncomfortable, like you would remain stagnant. And sometimes when we fight back against these feelings, is our brain has a way of breaking through for us. Like our brain works in some crazy, unconscious, subliminal ways. And when you start to notice that tension, you're trying to suppress it, you're trying to be like, no, like, I'm happy, I'm happy,
如果我们从未质疑过自己的梦想或在世界上的位置会怎样？如果你从不逼迫自己去面对不适，你就会停滞不前。有时，当我们与这些感觉抗争时，我们的大脑会找到一种为我们突破的方式。就像我们大脑以一些疯狂的、无意识的、潜意识的方式运作一样。当你开始注意到这种紧张感，你试图压制它，你试图表现得像，不，我是快乐的，我是快乐的，
I'll just keep pushing forward. Something is going to change. The thing that will often change is our mindset and our attitude and our brain will break forward and create this crisis for us. And it really forces us to rethink our desires and our intentions in life. it forces us to question what we actually want and importantly to change our pathway or our direction in a decade in life in which that's actually an expected part of our journey. Right.
我会继续向前推进。事情总会改变的。通常会改变的是我们的心态、态度，而我们的大脑会突破并为我们制造这场危机。它真的迫使我们重新思考我们在生活中的欲望和意图。它迫使我们质疑我们真正想要的是什么，更重要的是，在人生的十年中改变我们的道路或方向，而这实际上是我们旅程中预期的一部分。对吧。
Like that's why it happens at this age because this is the time to do it. Like we, you know, most of us don't have kids or a mortgage or financial responsibilities. We can actually make these decisions. So if you are unhappy right now, if you don't want to do your job, if you don't want to work 9 to 5 if you don't want to live where you're living and your brain has pushed you to a point of crisis, it's actually a great opportunity to change things. Like in many ways, you can say yes to a lot of the opportunities that will come your way, especially if your quarter life crisis has been, I think, triggered by some kind of dissatisfaction with your career and feeling like the path you're on
就像这就是为什么它发生在这个年龄，因为这是做这件事的时候。就像我们，你知道，我们大多数人没有孩子、房贷或经济责任。我们实际上可以做出这些决定。所以如果你现在很不快乐，如果你不想做你的工作，如果你不想朝九晚五地工作，如果你不想住在你现在居住的地方，而你的大脑把你推到了危机的边缘，这实际上是改变现状的绝佳机会。就像在许多方面，你可以对许多向你走来的机会说“不”，特别是如果你的四分之一人生危机，我认为，是由对你职业某种不满所触发的，并且感觉你所走的道路
isn't going to satisfy your purpose. It's an important catalyst to reconsider the those dreams we had as a child, the ones I was talking about before, and be like, would I be happier if I was doing that? Am I happy not doing that? Is this the life that I want for myself? But if you suppress those feelings, let this be a warning, if you ignore the dissatisfaction, not only are you never going to change, but those feelings aren't really going to go away. And you're going to find yourself at a point where you're probably quite unhappy and you're quite stagnant. So embrace it. I think this links to one of the second benefits of a quarter life crisis is that it opens a lot of new opportunities for you. So many new opportunities. When we are forced to
无法满足你的目标。这是一个重要的催化剂，让我们重新审视儿时那些梦想，也就是我之前谈到的那些，然后想：如果我做那个，我会更快乐吗？我不做那个会快乐吗？这就是我想要的生活吗？但如果你压抑这些感觉，这就当作是一个警告吧：如果你忽视这种不满，不仅你永远不会改变，而且那些感觉也不会真正消失。你会发现自己处于一个可能相当不快乐、相当停滞不前的境地。所以，拥抱它吧。我认为这与四分之一人生危机的第二个好处有关，那就是它为你打开了许多新机会。无数的新机会。当我们被迫
re-evaluate our life, we see things in a way we've never imagined them before. Suddenly, that path or the ambitions that were always really clear to us are not clear anymore. And this might seem scary, but often when we're so sure of our dreams, when we're so stubborn about them, it can make us pretty blind to the other options and opportunities that are out there. You know, when I was 16, all I wanted to be was a politician. And I was so sure of this, so passionate about achieving it for so many years, that's all I saw was this path forward to do the right degree, go to the right uni, you know, get a few internships, network with people, get a government job, move up. I really saw like nothing else. And because of that, I was really blind to other opportunities.
重新评估我们的人生时，我们会以从未想象过的方式看待事物。突然之间，那条曾经对我们来说非常清晰的道路或野心不再清晰了。这可能看起来很吓人，但通常当我们对自己的梦想如此笃定，当我们对它们如此固执时，它会让我们对身边的其他选择和机会视而不见。你知道，自我16岁起，我唯一想成为的就是一名政治家。我对此如此笃定，多年来对实现这个目标充满热情，我眼中看到的只有这条前行的路：读对的学位，去对的大学，你知道的，搞几份实习，与人建立人脉，得到一份政府工作，然后晋升。我真的什么也看不到。正因为如此，我对其他的机会视而不见。
So when that fell apart, when I was forced to question it, when after years, I realized that that's not what I wanted. It was incredibly difficult to wake up to other opportunities because I was just so focused on this one opportunity. And that meant that when I finally did realize this wasn't for me. Yeah, it was really scary, but I was reintroduced into this world of opportunities that I'd neglected for years. And there were so many other doors that opened for me when I didn't keep closing them myself. And, you know, like now, I do something that I love. Like, I get to make this show and talk about the things that really are really important to me. And I get to talk about psychology all the time. If I hadn't had that crisis a few years ago, I probably,
所以当这一切破灭时，当我被迫质疑它时，当多年后我意识到那并不是我想要的时，去接受其他机会是极其困难的，因为我太专注于这一个机会了。这意味着当我终于意识到这不适合我时。是的，这真的很可怕，但我重新接触到了这个我多年来一直忽视的机会世界。当我不再自己关上大门时，有那么多其他的门为我敞开。而且，你知道，就像现在，我做着我热爱的事情。就像，我能制作这个节目，谈论对我真正重要的事情。我能一直谈论心理学。如果几年前我没有经历那场危机，我可能，
I definitely wouldn't be doing this, and I'd probably be miserable. Like, I'd, like, think about that person, that poor girl, and that's all she wanted. And I'm like, gosh, if I had stuck to that, I don't think I would be as happy as I am now. So, like I said before, sometimes hard things happen for good reasons. It also reveals what's important to us and what's important to you. after that kind of storm passed and the skies become a lot clearer, I guess. So do our intentions and our purpose, because the clutter disappears. The only way through this crisis is to really examine your life and clear out what doesn't matter and what does.
我绝对不会做这个，我可能会痛苦不堪。就像，我，会想那个人，那个可怜的女孩，那曾是她全部的渴望。我想，天哪，如果我坚持那个，我想我现在不会这么快乐。所以，就像我之前说的，有时艰难的事情发生是有好原因的。它还揭示了什么对我们重要，什么对你重要。在那种风暴过去、天空变得清澈许多之后，我想也是如此。我们的意图和目标也是如此，因为杂乱消失了。度过这场危机的唯一方法就是真正审视你的生活，清理掉那些不重要的和重要的东西。
Sometimes that means ending our relationships, moving away from your hometown, quitting your job, beginning your hobbies, pursuing your opportunities, because we tend to stop prioritizing the things that don't align with our meaning when we go through this period of deep contemplation. There's this cliche that I think is often repeated a lot when we talk about this, and I hate to be cliche, but I am going to repeat it again here. Hitting rock bottom is such a great springboard up. I know, I know, it's so cliche, but like the saying always goes, right? You know, the only way is up.
有时这意味着结束我们的关系、离开你的家乡、辞掉工作、开始培养爱好、追求你的机会，因为当我们经历这段深度沉思的时期时，我们往往会停止优先处理那些与我们的意义不符的事情。有一个老生常谈的克里希，当我们在谈论这个时经常被重复，我讨厌成为老生常谈，但我还是要在重复一遍。跌入谷底是一个很好的弹跳板。我知道，我知道，这太老套了，但俗话说得对，对吧？你知道，唯一的出路就是向上。
if we never hit rock bottom right we never get pushed to the point of questioning our lives because we remain where it's you know just comfortable enough to feel safe and secure but not happy and when we hit a crisis point where we have to re-evaluate everything because it's falling apart you're kind of forced into a place of reflection and you gain a new perspective and you're given this like magical magical opportunity of a fresh start. You gain humility, you see that life is not black and white, and you begin to let go of the things that you can't control. Because when you're in like a crisis, when you're in like fight or flight mode, like those unimportant things like how people perceive you or what you're wearing or whether people think I'm smart enough or whether I'm doing the right internships
如果我们从未跌入谷底，对吧，我们就永远不会被逼到质疑我们生活的地步，因为我们留在那些，你知道的，刚好舒适到足以感到安全和安心却并不快乐的地方。当我们遇到一个危机点，我们必须重新评估一切，因为一切都在崩溃，你有点被迫进入一个反思的地方，你获得了新的视角，你得到了这个神奇的、重新开始的神奇机会。你获得了谦逊，你看到生活不是非黑即白的，你开始放手那些你无法控制的事情。因为当你处于危机中，当你处于战斗或逃跑模式时，那些不重要的事情，比如别人怎么看你、你穿什么、别人是否觉得你够聪明、或者我是否在做对的实习
or getting the right jobs and all these things, like they really don't matter because you're in crisis mode. You're in a meltdown. The only things that matter to you are the things that are really important. And in that way, you get to identify them clearer. Finally, I think a quarter-life crisis strengthens your core values. I know I talk a lot about values on the show because I think they are really important to establish in our 20s
或者找到对的工作以及所有这些事情，真的不重要，因为你处于危机模式。你在崩溃。对你唯一重要的是那些真正重要的东西。通过这种方式，你能更清晰地识别它们。最后，我认为四分之一的人生危机强化了你的核心价值观。我知道我在节目中经常谈论价值观，因为我认为它们在我们的20多岁时非常重要，需要确立
and to take some time to think about, like, what are the five things that are most important to you? Is it honesty? Is it humility? Is it creativity? Independence? And often we go through life, especially early adulthood, really following the values that were instilled to us by our parents and by our families and our communities. These values are really easy to partake in because they don't require any effort, and they've all we've ever known. But often, a trigger for a quarter-life crisis is that these values no longer fit.
并花时间去思考，比如，对你来说最重要的五件事是什么？是诚实吗？是谦逊吗？是创造力吗？独立吗？通常我们度过生活，尤其是成年早期，真的在遵循我们的父母、家人和社区灌输给我们的价值观。这些价值观很容易参与其中，因为它们不需要任何努力，而且它们是我们所知道的一切。但通常，引发四分之一人生危机的导火索是，这些价值观不再适用了。
and they no longer fit how we perceive the world. So we're forced to either abandon them and create new ones or strengthen elements of them that we do believe in. I think religion is a good example here. You know, a lot of us, I would say, grew up in some kind of religious society or with some kind of religious background or religious knowledge, and often that revolves around a god, or some kind of traditional belief of good and bad.
它们不再符合我们对世界的认知。所以我们被迫要么放弃它们并创造新的，要么强化我们确实相信的它们的元素。我认为宗教在这里是一个很好的例子。你知道，我想我们会说，我们许多人都成长于某种宗教社会，或者有着某种宗教背景或宗教知识，通常这围绕着一个神，或者某种关于善与恶的传统信仰。
And those values are often instilled in us by our parents who are raising us the best they can, giving us the knowledge that their parents gave them. But you actually really need to consider whether you believe in those things, and whether you believe in the values that were instilled to you as a child. You know, using that religion example, you might no longer believe in God
这些价值观通常由尽最大努力抚养我们、将他们父母给他们的知识传授给我们的父母灌输给我们。但你实际上真的需要考虑你是否相信这些事情，以及你是否相信作为一个孩子被灌输给你的价值观。你知道，以宗教为例，你可能不再相信上帝
if you test that feeling and you test that relationship. and you test that belief. But what you find you do believe in is something bigger or that, you know, love is at the core of everything. And that brings us comfort because we know we believe in that. It's not just something that our parents have told us. We know we can trust that belief because we created it for ourselves. And sometimes it means going through a crisis and a meltdown and a period of real deep confusion to figure that out. So if there is one takeaway, from this episode. It's that this experience, this crisis in our lives that a lot of us find ourselves going through in our 20s and our journey and all of those terrifying questions we
如果你去检验那种感觉，检验那种关系，检验那种信仰。但你发现你所相信的是更伟大的东西，或者，你知道的，爱是万物的核心。这给我们带来了安慰，因为我们知道我们相信这一点。这不仅仅是我们的父母告诉我们的。我们知道我们可以信任这种信仰，因为它是我们为自己创造的。有时这意味着经历危机、崩溃和真正的深度困惑期来弄清楚这一点。所以，如果说本期节目有一个收获。那就是这段经历，我们在20多岁时发现自己正在经历的我们生活中的这场危机，我们的旅程以及所有那些可怕的问题，我们
tend to ask ourselves about our values and our purpose. Yeah, it's really going to be quite scary, right? Like, I'm not going to deny that. And if you're someone who's experiencing that right now, like it's hard. It's really hard. But it's also freaking fantastic, because without this experience, we never get to grow or actually decide for ourselves in this moment what we actually want and what we're here to do. So I hope this episode was helpful. It was a bit of a pep talk for me as well. Like I said, I think I'm definitely going through something like this right now.
倾向于问自己关于我们的价值观和我们的目的。是的，这真的很可怕，对吧？就像，我不会否认这一点。如果你是一个现在正在经历这一切的人，这很难。这真的很难。但它也超级棒，因为没有这段经历，我们永远无法成长，也无法在此刻真正为自己决定我们真正想要什么以及我们来这里是为了做什么。所以我希望这期节目对大家有所帮助。对我来说这也是一次动员讲话。就像我说的，我想我肯定正在经历这样类似的事情。
And really kind of questioning, like, is this what I want? Like, is this who I want to be? and it's really, really terrifying because I don't know the answer. Like, you probably don't know it either. I don't know why I'm asking you. I guess I'm asking myself, right? Like, I want to put myself through this and through these questions because I know that when I get to the other side,
并且真正开始质疑，比如，这真的是我想要的吗？这真的是我想成为的人吗？这真的，真的很可怕，因为我不知道答案。就像，你可能也不知道。我不知道我为什么要问你。我想我在问我自己，对吧？就像，我想让自己经历这一切，经历这些问题，因为我知道当我到达另一边时，
I will be more sure of myself and I'll be more sure of what's going to make me happy. So I hope that is the case for you as well. And I want to thank you for listening. Thank you so much for joining me for this episode. If you enjoyed it, if you feel. feel cool to do so. Please feel free to subscribe, follow, leave a five-star review on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you are listening. I really appreciate it. You really help the show grow. And it's just crazy to me that like I get to do this. Like that's just crazy. So I really want to
我会对自我更加确定，我会对什么能让我快乐更加确定。所以我希望对你来说也是如此。我想感谢你们的收听。非常感谢你们和我一起参与这一期节目。如果你喜欢它，如果你觉得这样做很酷。请随意订阅、关注，在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你收听的任何地方留下五星评价。我真的很感激。你真的在帮助节目成长。对我来说，我能做这个简直太疯狂了。就像这太疯狂了。所以我真的很想
thank everyone who has been listening these past few months, this like past a year and a half. It's just like crazy. I don't know. This is kind of a tangent. But I'm feeling very grateful at the moment, so I really appreciate the support. And I appreciate that you enjoy this show. It's just such a magical feeling. And we will be back next week for a Christmas episode, a holiday season episode. I know. I had to do it.
感谢过去几个月、过去一年半以来一直在收听的每一个人。这简直太疯狂了。我不知道。这有点离题了。但我此刻感到非常感激，所以我真的很感激大家的支持。我也很感激你们喜欢这个节目。这真是一种神奇的感觉。我们下周将回来制作一期圣诞节目，一期节日季节目。我懂的。我必须这么做。
I'm so excited. And so excited. And thank you again for listening. Have a lovely, lovely day. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
我太兴奋了。超级兴奋。再次感谢你们的收听。祝你们拥有美好美好的一天。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、体能和培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-Heart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。
On the Look Back at a Podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it
在播客《回顾过去》中。来自1979年，对我来说那是一个大时刻。对卡来说1984年很大。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马可·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加梅斯主持的《艰难学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，而在其他任何地方进行这些对话其实并不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你对这个特定的测试做了两次手脚，对吧？我对测试做了一次手脚。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。